donna's in utica new york hi donna how
are you
hi dave i'm doing well how are you
better than i deserve what's up
okay so i have a whole life insurance
policy
um and i i would like to cash it in
i just found out that there's dividends
on the policy which i believe are
tax-free
um i have a loan out on the policy
and a cash value on the policy a small
cash value
so my question is should i take out the
dividends first or if i cash it in will
i get those dividends that i have on my
policy
you should get them if they haven't been
used to buy paid up additions
yeah they have not i didn't even realize
that they would have just
been added to your cash value
what's that i'm sorry it would have just
been added to your cash value and none
of this is going to be taxable
so they're saying i got forty three
hundred dollars in dividends
and a cash value of fifty three hundred
dollars but then
they said i'm going to be capital gains
stacked on 80 no yeah
okay i doubt it so here here's
here's how the calculation works okay
the dividends are not taxable period
okay how much is your loan
the loan is 15 000. i just okay so
these numbers are above the loan being
paid back right
yeah okay because you don't get the loan
money
i mean you get you got the money has the
cash value has to pay off the loan first
so right now as far as the cash value
whether it has a capital gains or not
here's the basis
all the money you've ever paid into this
policy
added together is your basis
so do you remember what your premium is
forty dollars a month
okay for how long have you been doing
this
uh 1992. so 500 bucks a year for
30 years okay
you don't have any capital gains
30 times 500 all right is more than
your cash value you would only have a
you would only have a capital gain is if
all the premiums you have paid in
overtime is equal to
more than your cash value
are less than your cash value and it
never is because these things suck
so bad they're horrible i know okay
now let me tell you how a dividend works
just for the fun of it
okay now how old are you
60. okay do you need life insurance
does someone count on your income to eat
no are you married yeah
okay do you all have a pile of money
other than this
well i mean i have and we have savings
but
i mean i probably only have about ten
thousand dollars in savings
so how does he eat if you die
well he's working and has a retirement
okay
all right so if you don't need life
insurance then it's fine if you want to
buy some life insurance
you would buy it prior to canceling this
that's thing one
now a dividend is not taxable
because it is not a dividend
in the true sense of the word a dividend
is when a company
makes a profit like home depot and they
pay their stockholders some of the
profit
out and that's a dividend okay life
insurance dividends
have nothing to do with that at all
there are two kinds of companies in the
life insurance world stock company and a
participating company
stock company never pays dividends the
only ones that do are participating
the stockholders of a participating
company are the policyholders
so if you have a state farm policy or
you have a
i don't know who's whose is yours with
credential yeah credentials
participating okay
and that means that the policyholders
are the owners now in order for them to
give you
an owner profit back
they would have had to charge you extra
to create that profit does that make
sense
yes so there's no dividend if you're if
i own the company
and i want to and i want to buy
something from myself
and i charge myself a little extra so
that i can give myself back some more
money that's nice of you
that's nice of me and then so that's why
the irs has deemed
life insurance policies that have
dividends to be non-taxable because the
actual ruling states
it's the return of a deliberate
overcharge
right okay and that's why it's not
taxable it's it's a shell game it's a
scam
and so uh it's of no benefit at all so
that that's just
all that is is you paid too much for the
policy all these years so now you got
four thousand of it coming back
that's all that was right then on top of
that you paid too much to build up a
cash value
and you're going to get that back but
you're not even getting back all that
you paid in so you got no taxes on that
either
so that that's the moral of the story on
that and and these whole life that's you
know
one more way that these holiday
or one more way that these uh whole life
policies suck
it's just unbelievable and by the way
you paid extra to create
the savings account in there called cash
value and when you wanted your money out
you had to go
borrow your own money and pay them
interest to do that so that loan you've
been paying interest on was where you
borrowed your own money
in this whole time do these companies
take that money
and then they go invest it somewhere
else and keep the gap right oh yeah
yeah yeah absolutely so they're like a
long-term interest-free bank
virtually interested that is making
money on their stuff right that's why
you know that's why in any skyline in
america
you know you drive around there are two
tall buildings
banks and life insurance companies right
you built them people wow you built them
in both cases you gave them your money
and uh you know this is the great the
great credit card scam the great
you know car loan scam uh the great the
great
whole life life insurance scam and
some of the wealthiest companies in
america are life insurance companies
because they have all of the money like
hers sitting on the books
in the commercial real estate business
if you want to go get a shopping mall
for uh 26 million dollars and you want
to bought you want to find a
lender for that the primary lender is
life insurance companies
they do functioning as their own bank
insiders they do
tons of commercial lending and they're
lending her money
and they make the spread and they make
the spread that's right
wow just follow the money baby
just follow the money and you'll see
where it is you'll see what's been going
on so
oh man i had never heard that uh you get
the blessing of them
increasing your rate and then saying hey
here you go here's some of it back
look how look how benevolent yeah right
yeah
wow so you know if as long as your cash
value now if her cash value does include
her
more her loan amount so shh
i'm gonna rethink that she probably had
about a fifteen thousand dollar basis
and she said she had a fifteen thousand
loans so she might actually have a cash
flow a capital gain
you'd have to see your tax professional
to be sure and double check that but the
way you calculate your basis is
all the premiums you've ever paid in
is your basis and as long as your cash
value is not higher than that number
it almost never is then there is no
capital gain on it because you lost
money you lost money right
you didn't keep up with inflation
putting 40 bucks under your bed for
yeah 20 or 30 years you'd have been
better off putting in a fruit jar you'd
end up with more money
wow at the end of this story wow you
wouldn't have the life insurance but
if you put your money in a fruit jar and
buy an inexpensive term policy you'd end
up with more money yeah if you put the
money in a real investment
like a mutual and buy an inexpensive
term policy
good roth ira you'd end up with millions
of dollars more
wow i mean that little 40 a month policy
would have amounted to not
you know we're talking about 8 000 15
000 here these kinds of numbers it would
have been
hundreds of thousands of dollars wow
difference
instead they loaned money to a shopping
mall developer with
her money that's how it works
oh well that's discouraging yes
it is yeah well just you know
live and learn don't buy a whole life
that's right